hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to DPO the game about the
ocean where there are sharks and fishes
and seagulls and I'm not sure what else
but it's a multiplayer game in the IO
style and hopefully it's not going to
make me scream like a little bit oh I
didn't want to speck - oh I'm a ghost
fish all right we're gonna play this
choose your animal oh yeah gonna worm
I'll be this guy what I old your deep
tree creature going up to strange things
to your body
that sounds great why wouldn't I want
that a grown boy whoa hey buddy goes
look dangerous let's go
trace the oh oh ah nutritious oh this is
the good [ __ ] right here Oh what am I
now you give back part of the damage you
see what did I turn into some kind of
other I'm a king crab whoo I they know
me they know is a shark whoa get out
scary okay well at least I'm not dead he
missed thankfully you stupid know where
I am pressure pushing pushing in on me
pushing out on me Oh give me all that
good [ __ ] oh I'm a jellyfish now get
poisoned [ __ ] if you want some and
you know it touch my tentacle oh what am
i I'm a squirrel or hello don't be hurt
for three seconds and stay still to hide
I don't know how to stay still this this
train don't have no brakes hi spongebob
when did you die and get fast it's a big
screwed okay I'm fine then let me Hoover
up these glow balls mmm tasty delicious
glow balls lot of um yummy yummy you boy
well that's one wild lesson to play now
more whoo keep close to the top when
you're about to avoid that you're you're
assuming a lot about my survival rate
here which I don't think I'm gonna
survive very hard oh that's a submarine
and that's a peg square out I'm a bird
Wow heavy join me on the bottom two a
dime oh I'm being feasted upon you
[ __ ] [ __ ] king crabs
[ __ ] I gots quitted mmm try again
oh I'm a jellyfish okay alright then
left me with a little bit that's nice
Wow
Oh wha ah there we go I'm a squid boy
excuse me you don't want none of this
look at my sick maneuvers oh you think
you can outmaneuver me I'm a squid of
the sea you gotta get to the surface you
know about to evolve you wouldn't know
much about that excuse you
excuse you I'm a bird now I'm gonna fly
in the sky oh boy those look tasty
apparently not I'm just lying around
oh hi okay well wait whoa whoa what the
hell was that I'm pooping which is
awfully nice don't know why I'm pooping
but not an excuse you I got a dive for
my food what kind of [ __ ] ooh do ya
I don't don't don't know I hate the
otter aah aah
started from the bottom and now we're
back at the [ __ ] bottom again oh god
damn it I just I just got splitted aah
you speared me with your dick kit oh my
god there's so much here oh my god it's
a bonanza oh come on oh oh I'm about to
be bone and ugh yi yi yi yi I found me
oh no no no no there's so many threats
I'm a bird again on the bird again I'm
bird again oh boy that don't look good
you ok I'm a seagull that crap went
flying I don't know why oh hello your
you shouldn't be up here you shouldn't
be up here give me oh yeah oh you
shouldn't be up here either welcome to
my Beach oh I get it I'm supposed to eat
these things and not be ok goodbye
I don't know why these animals that
shouldn't be flying or flying that they
are yeesh I don't know why there's a sea
otter just good enough in there ah get
come here you well I want you huh got ya
too bad for you I'm poisoned but well I
shouldn't have done that seems to have
been detrimental Mike oh I'm shouldn't
be down here okay gonna be down here oh
no no oh no I was about to fall
I was about to shed my skin and lurch
forward in my new form Oh such an
[ __ ] such an [ __ ] okay guys start
going up there we go nope I'm a bird now
I shouldn't be down here little boy
gotta go gotta go it's Goosby I pooped
on that sea otter a get some good man
buy something I mean get on my my poo oh
you [ __ ] [ __ ] get out of here you
otter [ __ ] someone curses to y'all just
want some of the smoke alright not again
it's the same for goon ah
scuri I thought it'd go good dad push me
okay but I don't know what that was but
it flew by and I don't know uh yeah it's
um you want some yeah I got more if you
want some got a lot of it surplus supply
but it it Costco I got a lot of sub want
to get it get it off me you know what
it's a burden of this much some you know
you got golf load where you can
diversify your assets whenever you got a
lot of some so if you want some kind of
bring my phone up and get my pager down
you know give me good if you want it
I'll give it to you for a discount if
you want to garage sales tell if you're
into that sort of thing I know I am I
don't know about you and I live your
life man but if you want some come get
it a lot of it oh what am i next
I don't know what oh you can also eat
flappy ducks how do I do that how do I
pay whoo Oh floppy dogs I got one I
think so that's what was Oh
that's what was getting those oh I am
trapped help help please dog God thank
you I mean you didn't help me at all I
helped myself begs more but like you
know
oh you were there and I didn't die so
thank you
no no no yes yes yes oh god I'm being
changed again right Sal and thing oh god
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead or who voted
gold not him good you should have done
it he would have gotten me but I did I
persuaded him with my charm and you want
some Oh double me in my body
oh whoops sorry oh you trying to hide
there oh well I guess that worked soon I
didn't get your things good good can't
complain jobs good life is good just
sucking up balls in the bottom of the
ocean not bad alive die you know I like
to scream random it's pretty good for my
lungs ah oh yes it somehow worked out
for me I don't know how but it did I'm
just trying to get by oh boy I don't
know what the hell that was no I've been
pierced that you I just get thank you
for distracting him well that didn't
almost was bad now I'm an otter though
that was it that's an a chain of events
that I could never have anticipated oh
I'm a beaver I'm not an otter I'm a
beaver stupid me who'da thought ah hey
you want fight I can fight you I could
fight you I'm not gonna fight you but I
could help
gotcha you're in my paw you're my little
paw come with me thinking meeting this
guy oh he's a parasite no he's on me oh
that makes sense I think I've no idea to
make sense you're gonna come bursting
out of my chest later when I give them
enough food am I already dead is that
how this works
Oh oh hello excuse me excuse you Kim wow
that's a lot of flaps new scheme I get
some flaps oh I love this flappy combo
[ __ ] douche Oh gimme that oh yeah that's
good [ __ ]
well that's the good [ __ ] lost my
passenger but you know hey you know easy
come easy go
piggies thank you whoa that's dangerous
ah you missed me see ice-cream as a
natural defense really get some going by
going I mean going away not like in a
sexual way yep Turtles isn't spelled the
end for me I'm gonna die I don't have
any excuse juice God that was not as
nearly as fast as I was hoping but it
you've done the trick it got away from
pretty good hates crab you won't get eat
yeah you don't that's right live and
learn and then get loves and get the
[ __ ] out of my neighborhood all you came
back all you can't oh no I'm gonna beat
this guy Oh
mimics I don't know what that means cool
cool I think yeah I'm a minute cool
got it nice I know get blinded you're
blind you're blind oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy that guy's mean oh he's very mean
oh god he's mean he still wants me good
another I'm still tractive but don't do
that you one cent
ooh Skoosh gotcha ha I'm a crab now but
I'm not really anybody want to try to
get crab you're gonna get ah he got
fooled he was fooled by me I'm the fool
err he got fooled all over himself ah
the mimic works apparently I didn't know
if it would or not but apparently it
works ow ow
uh-huh you thought you were bumping up
against us screwed not quite okay we're
all kinds of wrecked ah no one can stop
me no one can stop me I'm not what I
seem to be now when I came to be no okay
anyway I lost I did pretty good dog that
was a fun one that was legitimately a
fun one I liked that a lot
so uh like I said before there's a ton
of these Isle games on this website
there's just tons of tons they make it a
whole mess of these but this is a lot of
fun so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to play these games
I'll put them in the link in the
description below if you want to play
any more of these games or you want me
to play
let me know which one of these are good
and I'll play them they're really fun
too
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]